do you think you need my my help don't
need to hold your hand to work out what
the equation of the directrix is
remember I said it all comes from these
two equations the first thing we do is
subtract what do you reckon just do this
time all right you walk me through it
this time what are we going to do okay
take out take out the e okay now which
one's easier si one and si 2 we would
think about those before okay this time
we're adding them which makes things a
little easy to visualize is this a 1 and
say say so you got em up you get again
you get the major axis tension so that's
to think what happens over here a 1 plus
R you sometime I don't split yet because
I think I think we took the hard yards
trying to work out what this was I
reckon you can get it if you think you
have it come here Bob look otherwise
give you two staring at your paper for
the pencil is ten times more effective
but it's there it's my board see if you
can draw something on there that's how
we worked out this for a month okay I've
seen it right a few times by the way the
key really is my cuz I could just give
you the formula but you just read it
from the different okay the point is and
what makes it fun it's hard if you're
gonna have any difficulty with it is
seeing where the distances are you have
to see them okay not just be able to
parent out okay if you can pair it then
you'll be able to you'll be able to tell
me about what were they 16 and 9 or
something right you'll be able to work
out what the all the features are S is
fine okay so you knew the textbook
exercise would be
but when you get to an actual exam
question which doesn't just you know and
is to you unlike a silver platter you
know they have a free mark okay when
there's a challenge it's not quite
something you've seen before
this is the kind of skill you need to
develop make sense all right well you
haven't quite got there yet probably the
easiest thing to do is to try and break
these things up into components that are
a little easier to work with
okay so for instance have a look at this
a to and length the long one okay it's
hard to work with it so let's break it
up into some more manageable pieces for
instance from o2a2
that distance there the semi-major axis
on the left hand side okay because of
that symmetry right or a two is equal to
away one correct so what I could do just
to visualize for myself is I could take
that guy and I can move him over here
that distance I just amazing this listen
to the same okay
and all I've got left on there the lates
I'll trying to add up so I've got this
component left of a to n this part that
I reflected over for the other side and
then I've got this little guy who's
hanging off on the side I thought this
one monomer win and another wonderful
win why is for in significant because
just like before we worked out the
quotes of the focus this is going to
give you the equation the directrix
that's what om gives you so here when we
have two times n so you should have that
okay the important part is how much
they've got there right again common
factor of two what are we actually after
oh man is what we want so you divide
through by E
okay so being that this is a distance
like it might be whatever that is it's
there the equation of this line would be
x equals a only
okay so this implies or implying the
directrix is there we go okay now how do
you feel about that is that is that good
we made some decent progress yeah it's
okay that's good we've sort of worked
out with focuses sort of like that where
the directrix is and we have a problem
what's the problem what did we see how
to find again okay so we were setting
out to find the focus sorted okay the
direct race disorder okay we've known
about a thing about that he's centricity
okay so there's a piece of information
on here that we haven't taken into
account so far and I've sort of been
alluding to a by the fact that
everything I've been doing has been on
this axis what information am I missing
yeah I haven't accounted anything to do
with the minor axis have I it's big this
is just kind of been well he hasn't
appeared at all because we haven't
looked okay so what I want you to search
for now there's a lot of pieces on the
board here the semi-major axis the semi
minor axis and the Easter suit must be
related in some way okay because when
you change this you necessarily change
the other two are we gonna get a
relationship between them there's just
enough time left today me to give you
some time to give the shot on your own
no I hate giving things a shot on my
earning get something I will eventually
but not before you've thought about it
okay so figure there's the challenge
what's the equation that unites all of
them together okay